belle ragazze che nessuno video sono fa
vj ci siamo su un 4 rex che sguardo
satanico praticamente ragazzi wake
lorenzo sarebbe un gioco dove bisogna
malmenare il proprio ex c'è insomma è
una cosa strana per i depressi cronici
in amore praticamente quando avete delle
delusioni in amore e guardate questo
video e siete a posto e credo dato che
non è vero e proprio gioco ma più
un'animazione c'è una roba tipo sei
ragazzi geniale ragazza no vabbè line
come ho fatto a non pensarci prima una
cosa ovvia prendete spunto e raccomanda
vediamo che che si tranciano di coach è
una macchina che lui da traiano mica
dire così solo perché ci hai soldi
pronti a può pure proietti come se non
bastasse fantastico papà era mio padre
quello da papà più bravo complimenti
ora che lo dico a mamma è un regalo dei
guantoni da boxe alimenterei come noi vi
sembra un penny sbattuto la gente brava
tesoro tailleur mega qualcuno ha voglia
di spiegarmelo questo cioè no non ho
capito
ok lascio per portatile creativi abbiano
facebook che è peggio di quanto pensassi
va bene era più fisica la croce non ho
capito se quella sinistra sono contro di
me oppure sono contro di lei non abbia
comunque per san valentino tesoro tutto
tuo
io lo sapevo è la madonna becca schifo
quello è ovviamente il succo di fragola
perché le fragole sono romantiche tesoro
vero non è stato abbastanza triste
questo cos'è sta roba
un libro che cos'è sta roba qui no
ragazzi che sta questa non l'ho capita
un rifugio anti atomico se esplode
qualcosa sul caso sono convinto che
sportarena pesca
ok così a questo scorretto è per farti
capire è stato alquanto violento va bene
il pacco di soldi mancano certo già dato
di san valentino tipo anche questo
guarda che bravo che fai la brava
ragazza ok questo è tra tutti quelli che
ho fatto finora e quello che ho capito
di meno ma va bene le scarpe né scarpino
anche no è la cosa più tenera che abbia
mai visto ma anche da fuori da [ __ ]
lei è più bella
togliti vabbè che esagerazione o mio dio
è tanto la ex ragazzo se ne frega non ho
capito una carta di credito come oggi
comprarti tutte queste cose con la mia
carta di credito brutta [ __ ] guarda che
non puoi spendere più di 25 euro con
questa carta enoteche compri cosa che
non mi è rimasto più un cazzo [ __ ]
diverse anche scappata i miei soldi
franza ma perché ridarmi la roba almeno
queste insegne ragazzi e non dare mai
una carta di credito
la propria fidanzata ricordatevelo
questo che è importante effetto ragazzi
ho finito gli oggetti del ragazzo adesso
passiamo a quelli della ragazza che
questo qua mi sembra più carino di tutti
un gorilla che casa fan gorilla soli di
scorta zio ma sto cosa che in testa con
i fili anche nei tutti che è scappato
rigori se ne va da solo perfetto ma
grazie a vico via verdi prati di un peso
non indifferente
ecco qua chi è e stato bello complimenti
poltrone dai poltrona una poltrona per
due da viene anche tutti i successi viso
sdraiato beh ma poi c'è la testa pene
tesoro tesoro stavo guardando la partita
ti va seri pony qualcosa che sa in mano
per poi tanto il mio più grosso è vabbè
cazzo fai di sviluppo ma allora sei
[ __ ] ma anche scassato la poltrona se
non era contento proprio se questo aereo
ascolta zia ma l'hai presa tu per me è
l'aereo che sta facendo
[Musica]
forse era sta roba troppo ma troppo
cazzo picchia una donna cazzo rocky
balboa c'è su santo devo rivederla un
secondo questa cosa non l'ho capita
[Musica]
ma cos'è qui ma perché va bè ragazzi
no no no no le scarpe dai usare scarpe
mio dio
cosa fai l'ilo che mi tradisci trai a io
piango sulla tua porta e tu te ne vai
con un altro fa infilare nel culo è
stato diagnosticato roba sta facendo ci
vado a comprare scarpe anno ti schiaccio
sull'armadio tutte le scarpe per lei ma
donna che uomo sono perfido bello i
complimenti sono un genio del male
ragazzine ma sono tre ancora io ho paura
di vedere il cos'è non fare la [ __ ]
csai aperto sopra la mia the mist a
pisciando qualcuno ma buongiorno era un
acquario ragazzi un po più di senso in
queste cose va bene mancano due proprio
un presto sono anche caduto sul computer
c'è ma povero portatile cazzo è stato
orribile
ci siamo ragazzi proprio in continuo
perché ormai tanto siamo arrivati
ammazza che boccia amica mia macché ma
che cazzo state vi andrebbe un manager
ragazze cosa fai in a birgi
ok perché in questo mondo non si può
neanche più sbirciare dalla serratura ma
dimmi te dove siamo arrivati bene è
finito qui una ragazza è stata una
grinza più brutta della mia vita però
voglio fare una cosa che mi dà
soddisfazione prima di concludere perché
veramente è stato una liberazione è
stata c'è tipo questa ma è un easter egg
ho trovato una cosa nascosta nel gioco
ragazzo fantastico
oddio ei coloni è stato orribile bene
non era questa la cosa che mi rendeva
felice ma in realtà volevo volevo
prenderlo portati lati in faccia trova
menti perfetto ragazzo è stato
istruttivo
direi che ragazzi spero che mi sia
servito da tutorial su come vendicarsi
della propria ex soprattutto ragazzi se
succede in qualsiasi cosa nella vita
ricordatevi non guardi fai cagare in
faccia perché potrebbe essere spiacevole
anche ragazzi concludo che l'episodio
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
cagate a parte nel vero senso della
parola
sei video vi è piaciuto come solito
lasciato commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook come lo divido
trovata una descrizione senza vestiti
scheletrici vediamo al prossimo video
della ragazza
[Musica]